right i i'm literally running
again to work
running to the
to the tube
and this guy starts running besides me
and he's like he's like he's like miss
miss miss miss and he's trying to talk
to me i said to him like excuse me like
i'm i'm literally i'm running late i've
got no time to talk to you
he said i just want to tell you look
nice i said okay thank you cool
i'm i've still got to go to work right
bye left the next day he sees me again
it's the same thing obviously i'm not
running to this train station this day
and i say to him that i've got a
boyfriend i'm not interested he's like
your boyfriend doesn't have to know you
can come to you can come to my place i'm
dying no
i'm not interested the next day again he
sees me and he sees me he's here and he
he's it and again it's the same thing
daily
daily for a week like
do you not think that's harassment
that's just one guy right no but the p
point did you not think he was also
going to work though maybe that's why
he's bumping onto you into you daily at
the same time he's just like like he
makes it across from him okay i just
would not care
like i just okay just don't reply yeah
then just keep that is that harassment
you don't think that's harassment
if you've repeatedly told a guy i'm not
interested i don't want anything to do
with you some someone call it someone
call that persistence
i grew up in nigeria and if i come to
you and approach and you said no and
i'll ask you a simple question what
percentage of chance have i got if you
say two percent that's good enough i've
got something to work with
you're crazy
you should be like you do you hear that
like they've been like there's so much
like there's so much privilege of being
able to say like
man like that men approach me every day
that doesn't happen to everyone yeah and
so it's like it's like you're
complaining about
that
but don't you think that women in
general get approached
more
anyway yeah boohoo right
who cares you don't have to like it you
don't have to like it but you don't have
to let it bother you like you're like
letting it bother you is a choice yeah
like reflected i'm pretending it's like
harassment or something that someone
sees you and compliments you it is
harassment because you don't know how
it's going to go you don't know if it's
going to like escalate to something else
so
you think this guy is going to kidnap
you in your way to work
after telling you you look nice
the guy that has watched documentaries
that's a horror story that's like going
to the extreme it's not the north you
know your percentage chance of getting
kidnapped and killed is do you know how
many women died
do you know how many people i have
strangers in my apartment four times a
week you'll be fine
you'll be fine you'll be surprised maybe
he's giving himself maybe give himself
10 chances right it's going to approach
you 10 times and if you say no 9 times
the 10th time you might say yes so it's
going to persist for those ten times and
at the tenth time you say no then it's
gonna walk away do you know i think
that's just like wearing women down or
like wearing people down i say it was
the opposite way say it was a woman
going after a man okay let's just take
the 52 women out of the millions
52. 52 women died this year yeah do you
know that that's a big number now are
you worried about people that died
emotional magnification how how many
how many
how many women do you not think that's a
big number
not not not one percent of uk's people
complain because one guy likes you
do you know how bizarre that sounds
right you know what i think it is is
that
4.496 million women and 52 died
how many women sorry 4.9 or 4.49 so 4.5
million women in london yeah that's a
lot of people yeah and 52 died am i is
this going to keep me up at night crying
scared
still a lot of people 52 people
this is like need to be right
because it's not you know it's not like
like i'm talking to you as an adult
right as an adult
like we could say
52 women out of 4.5 million is not a lot
yes
yeah i get that but it's still like it's
still
it's not a lot it's a lot
like it's not a lot in the comparison
but i just i still think that like 52
people dying they're still a bit mad no
not enough to scare me
i think more people get killed by
dolphins
dolphins like rape apparently yeah yeah
grape sorry great
great dolphins grape i mean yeah
yeah crazy doping
i was gonna look up like how many people
died from like a car crash or something
look up how many people died from
dolphin grapes how many people died
from dolphin
attacks
uh
i don't there's no number that's coming
up
okay so
why do we tell women to never settle
women don't sit we don't you don't say
that though women say that to themselves
and then they pretend that's what
everyone else is saying
western women by the way not the age of
asians do you think they're what what
age should women just look around and
grab the first guy she can
22
22 22.
at 22 you've graduated right you've been
through the whole school system you've
seen what's up there you've probably
tried a little bit of clubbing that
little bit of cabin is most likely a
direct representation of what it's going
to continue to be like
so i would say that's probably a good
time to be like all right let me just
jump this curve if you're clever
or if you're mentally like healthy if
you're a narcissist
you're gonna be like well i'm great so
i'm gonna wait out till someone realizes
how great i am i'm going to go to better
bars where better men will be and for
some reason they'll love me because i'm
the center of the universe and that's
how they reach the wall
i'm american you're gonna the chat's
gonna turn on you they're gonna hate me
no they're gonna love you
gonna no they today you last time
they'll love you today
people don't know like
okay
americans got up and they called dom 25
where you can do all the dumb things you
can think of when you but when you get
25 stop bit like an adult
so i would suggest that when you get 25
then get married
yeah i think but you've gone you've done
all the dumb stuff
yeah i think the problem is um what's
been advertised to women a lot is
you know enjoy your 20s
you know party do all of these things so
that you don't you know miss out on the
fun kind of thing and so they get to the
almost like 30 years old and above
and you know the reality hits which is
that most men
tend to want to date younger women and
yeah for fertility attractiveness all of
those other things and also less baggage
which is crucial to us
um
but yeah i i think yeah a lot of it's a
bit of a scam
i mean you're left over after 35 right
apparently
but once you get to 29 you're not
married and you just trouble ahead yeah
you're left over like 20 seconds
you're left over like 27 28 in my scene
what's your scene like at that time
you're kind of like yeah that's crazy
you know what the average age of first
marriage is in the uk 27. uh-uh 31. i
thought you won 31 31 in the uk it's 20
years
yeah unless they will have been together
before they get to 31.
that was just
yeah i don't know i don't think i don't
know what the numbers are
but even if they dated for like three
years before that's still 29. yeah but i
think the best advice you can give away
is find yourself a man yeah i agree i
agree with you i'm not like same page
i'm just like saying it's interesting
because that's the average age of first
marriage
i think the problem that women have got
is you the
voices in your echo chamber is just so
deceiving
you just lie to each other yeah i think
women actually like they actually
believe their own lives at some point
you ever had that when you argue with
someone who's so psychotic that like she
actually convinces herself what she's
saying makes sense